>> THANKS.
NOW TO ANOTHER STORY WE ARE
FOLLOWING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MEETING WITH
WORLD LEADERS AT THE G20 SUMMIT,
SET TO FACE OFF TOMORROW WITH
HIS CHINESE COUNTERPART.
EARLIER TODAY TRUMP SIGNED A
POSSIBLE NAFTA REPLACEMENT WITH
MEXICO AND CANADA.
>> THIS IS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
BALANCED TRADE AGREEMENT IN
HISTORY.
ALL OF OUR COUNTRIES WILL
BENEFIT GREATLY.
IT IS PROBABLY THE LARGEST TRADE
DEAL EVER MADE ALSO.
MANY, MANY JOBS ARE ALREADY
COMING TO COME BACK.
MANY COMPANIES ARE COMING BACK.
WE ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
>> BACK HOME.
THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS FOCUSSED
ON MICHAEL COHEN'S PLEA DEAL AND
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE RUSSIAN
PROBE.
>> THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDED
WITH THE RUSSIANS TO SUBVERT THE
ELECTION.
>> DONALD TRUMP SOUNDS LIKE A
CRIME BOSS.
>> THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
YOU WILL SEE A MAN WITH ALL
KINDS OF NEFARIOUS TIES.
>> TODAY IS THE FIRST DAY I
THOUGHT DONALD TRUMP MIGHT NOT
FINISH HIS TERM IN OFFICE.
THIS IS NOT THE WAY A HIGH
ELECTED OFFICIAL IS SUPPOSED TO
TALK.
IT'S THE WAY GUYS TALK TO ME
WHEN THEY ARE WEARING ORANGE
JUMPSUITS AND EXPLAINING WHY
THEY GOT DONE WRONG.
>> THEY ARE JUMPING AHEAD HERE.
>> YES, THEY ALREADY CONVICTED
THE GUY.
IN THE MEDIA, EVERY DAY THEY
BELIEVE IT'S A LAST DAY OF THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY.
THEY HAVE BEEN SAYING THAT SINCE
THE INAUGURATION.
I WATCHED THE CLINTON AFFAIR ON
A& AND E.
HE WAS TRYING TO KNOCK OUT DEALS
AND HAD THE NASTY SPECIAL
COUNSEL ON HIS BACK.
HE SAID LET ME GO BACK TO WORK
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I HAVE TO HELP THE COUNTRY.
WHAT DID THE VOTERS SAY?
HE HAD THE HIGHEST APPROVAL
RATING.
BECAUSE HE WANTED TO WORK HARD
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IF I WAS DONALD TRUMP I WOULD
SAY LET ME GET TO WORK.
HIS SIGNATURE TRADE DEAL HE
REPACKAGED IT SO AMERICAN AUTO
WORKERS AND DAIRY PRODUCERS AND
ENERGY AND WATER AND WINE, ALL
OF THESE INDUSTRIES ARE IN AN
IMPROVED POSITION.
HE HELD FIRM ON STEEL AND
ALUMINUM.
IT PUTS HIM IN A STRONG POSITION
IN WHAT HE NEEDS TO ACHIEVE
TOMORROW WITH THE CHINA TRADE
WAR.
WE ARE WINNING THAT TRADE WAR.
THE CHINA ECONOMY IS OFF 30%
SINCE THAT TRADE WAR STARTED.
THEY THOUGHT THE TARIFFS WOULD
BRING POLITICAL PRESSURE TO BEAR
ON THE PRESIDENT.
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
TRUMP ONLY LOST ONE SOYBEAN
DISTRICT IN THE MID-TERMS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE BIG
PICTURE.
GREG SAYS LOOK AT THE RESULTS.
THE RESULTS ARE STRONG.
YOU HAVE A NAGGING SPECIAL
COUNSEL ON THE OTHER END MAKING
LIFE MISERABLE.
>> GREG MIGHT HAVE A METAPHOR.
>> THANKS FOR SERVING ME UP THIS
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY.
TRUMP IS LIKE AN ICE CREAM STORE
WITH AMAZING PLAYOFFS.
GOBS OF JOBS.
ECONOMY CRUNCH.
OPTIMISM SWIRL.
NORTH KOREA CARAMEL AND THE
MEDIA IS ACROSS THE FEET FEEDING
OUT OF A GARBAGE CAN.
THEIR CHEEKS SWOLLEN WITH ROTTEN
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
BECAUSE ALL THEY WANT IS BAD
NEWS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAW IN THAT
MONTAGE.
THEY HAVE TRUMP SUCCESS DENIAL
DISORDER.
THEY CAN'T BEAR IT.
I LEARNED A LOT ABOUT TRADE.
I DON'T LIKE WHERE HE WAS GOING
WITH TRADE, BUT HE FORCED IT ON
ME.
I HAD TO LEARN ABOUT THE
IMBALANCES.
I AM AN OPINION PERSON.
I DON'T WANT TO LEARN ABOUT
TRADE.
I JUST WANT TO SHOUT ABOUT IT.
HE FORCED ME TO LEARN IT AND THE
GUY CARES ABOUT IT.
HE IS RIGHT AND GETTING STUFF
DONE.
THESE OTHER CREEPS ELSEWHERE ARE
TOO BUSY OBSESSING OVER THE
GARBAGE CAN FILLED WITH ROTTEN
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
>> JUAN, IS THE TRADE WAR
WORKING WITH CHINA?
>> OBVIOUSLY NOT.
YOU LOOK AT THE STOCK MARKET AND
MOST OF THE GAINS FOR THE YEAR
DISAPPEARED AND GM 14,000 JOBS.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S WORKING.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT,
YOU LOOK AT THE CHINA DEAL.
I MEANT JESSE.
>> WE LOOK ALIKE.
>> YOU DO.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT CHINA WHOSE
ECONOMY IS IN A SLUMP IS NOW ON
THE DEFENSIVE AND MORE WILLING
TO DEAL WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP?
WE DON'T KNOW THAT YET.
IN TERMS OF THE NAFTA DEAL, A
GOOD CONSERVATIVE NEWSPAPER LIKE
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAID
THIS IS THE STATUS QUO.
IT COULD BE WORSE.
YOU LOCK AT WHAT IS HIGHLIGHTED
IN TERMS OF THE NAFTA DEAL.
THAT'S DAIRY FARMERS.
WELL, IS IT A MUCH BETTER DEAL
FOR AMERICAN DAIRY FARMERS?
IT'S LESS THAN 1% INCREASE IN
THE QUOTA OF AMERICAN DAIRY
ALLOWED INTO CANADA.
BUT THERE IS NOW A SITUATION
WHERE CANADIANS DAIRY CAN'T BE
DUMPED IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> AND SENATE CHUCK SCHUMER
WOULD LIKE THAT.
>> THE QUESTION IS WHETHER OR
NOT CHUCK SCHUMER OR THE
DEMOCRATS APPROVE OF THIS DEAL.
>> EMILY YOU HAVE THE FLOOR.
>> I APPRECIATE YOUR UNIVERSITY
OF WASHINGTON HUSKIES.
A SHOUT OUT TO US WINNING THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
CHUCK SCHUMER VOTED NO IN 1993
AGAINST NAFTA.
WHAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM HIM
SINCE?
MORE SHOUTING ABOUT IT.
HIM COMING FORWARD AND SAYING
THIS IS NOT DOING US ANY GOOD.
HE DOESN'T MAKE ANY REFERENCE TO
THE PRICING SYSTEM GONE IN
CANADA.
FOR ME AS AN AMERICAN CITIZEN, I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY COMPROMISE
HASN'T BEEN REACHED.
I DON'T WANT MY ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO BE STANDING AND
SHOUTING FOR 20 YEARS WITHOUT
ANYTHING ACCOMPLISHED.
IT'S COMPROMISE WE ARE SENDING
THEM THERE FOR.
OTHERWISE THEY ARE NOT SERVING
US AND NOTHING IS GAINED.
ON CHINA, THE TRADE WAR IS
SIGNIFICANT.
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE LEVERAGE
GAINED OF THE THEFT GOING AND
THE EROSION OF QUALITY AND THEY
ARE FLOODING OUR COUNTRY WITH
DRUGS.
IT'S HAPPENING ALSO IN THE MAIL
SYSTEM.
THERE ARE ISSUES THAT NEED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE CONVERSATION.
THE ELECTED OFFICIALS NEED TO BE
MORE THAN WHINERS.
>> JESSE?
>> WITH JUAN'S COMMENT.
ON THE ECONOMY AND THE STOCK
MARKET.
YOU ARE WEEPING ABOUT YOUR
401-K.
>> WELL, YOU ARE A YOUNG FELLOW
>> THANKS FOR SAYING THAT.
IT'S THE MAKEUP.
THE STOCK LOSSES BACK TO SQUARE
1.
THE TECH SECTOR IS NOT DOING
WELL AND THE FED HAS BEEN
JACKING UP INTEREST RATES.
>> JACKING UP INTEREST RATES?
OH MY GOD.
>> THE MARKET RIPPED THIS WEEK
BECAUSE HE CAME OUT WITH
COMMENTS AND HINTED HE WOULD NOT
RAISE RATES AS MUCH AS HE WAS
INDICATING.
THAT'S WHY YOU SAW THE BIG JUMP
IN THE DOW.
THEN HE JAW BONED THE SAUDIS